- Hey gang, are we free
for a little rap session?
- Do you need help, or?
- [Voiceover] Nope.
- Do you want to go to
the conference room?
- Conference room is booked.
I need to figure out how to
book the conference room.
- So, what's up?
- Three weeks ago, I was entrusted
with our company's Twitter pass code.
That 's right, I beat out everyone,
including stupid Larry in Indianapolis.
And now, the time has come
for my inaugural tweet.
- Why did you wait three weeks?
- Well I lost the pass
code almost immediately.
- So you wanna run it by us?
- No, I want you to help me write it.
That's right, the training
wheels are off kiddos.
Welcome to the big leagues.
- That's a really big deal, I mean
everyone's gonna remember
our very first tweet.
- You think I don't know that Elliott?
You think that hasn't kept me up at night?
- Okay, it doesn't have to be a big deal.
How about, welcome new followers,
looking forward to serving you?
- Uck!
- [Elliott] Yawn!
- I need it to pop, like the poop emoji.
- Oh, that's my favorite emoji.
- Sure, that's great
for a personal account,
but we're professionals, so.
How about, excited to
be in the Twitterverse?
- That was pretty bad, but
I did like Twitterverse.
- Yes, that's good.
Let's work around that.
- Exploring the Twitterverse.
- I got an Airbnb in the Twitterverse.
Those are popular.
- Okay, I think we're
overthinking this a little.
You know, it's just a
handshake, keep it simple.
- Handshakes are the most
complicated part of my day.
- Focus, Elliott!
Twitterverse, we don't
wanna lose this high.
Mad Max and the Twitterverse,
welcome you online.
- Okay, you're just putting
popular things next to Twitterverse.
- Well, when I was in high
school, I used to try to sit
next to all the popular kids,
but it didn't work for me.
- I told you to stop telling
me stories like that Elliott,
it makes me very upset.
- I'm sorry, me too.
- Okay, let's keep it simple.
We're in the Twitterverse.
- [Both] Well versed in the Twitterverse!
(laughing)
- Yes, perfect.
Sent.
- But that doesn't make sense.
- To those not well versed.
(laughing)
- Don't use both hands.
- I'm sorry.
- So how'd we do?
- I'm getting a lot of death threats.
I think the right thing to
do in this case is engage.
- I would advise against that.
- Well you don't know anything Elliott.
- Okay.
- Oop, that was a penis.
- Oh.
- I forgot what they looked like.
- It's called a dick pic I think.
- Yeah, I am definitely missing a piece.
No I'm not done.
Because I'm missing a piece.